Film Courage: Storymaker?
What is this?
Cecilia Najar: Storymaker was borne out
of a land of blocked writers and it’s a
90 minute process that gives you prompts basically
to develop a character-driven story based
on anything.
It can take pickles, airplanes, hotels, etc.
Because we live in stories, we watch stories,
we’re so immersed in storytelling, it’s
in our DNA.
If you can stop thinking and just allow your
reaction to go forward, you will develop a
story.
I’m not saying it will be a great story,
but it will have a beginning, middle and end.
It will have characters that change and dilemmas
that will be interesting, an a genre that
could attract an audience.
These simple prompts, when you start allowing
your first reactions to come forward, you’ll
start to feel how powerful your internal storytelling
clock is and have much more confidence in
it.
That is the reason why I came up with this
process because the other thing is, as writers
we practice dialogue, we practice scenes,
right?
We practice all these things, but no one practices
the art of telling an entire story.
So if I can get you to tell an entire story
in 90 minutes with a beginning, middle and
end, good or bad (we don’t know), you could
do that once a week, which means you could
have 52 stories at the end of the year.
And how many good stories do you think you’d
have if you had 52 stories every year?
Probably more than you have now.
And you would also be building an incredible
muscle of developing ideas, of being able
to solve story problems, of knowing how characters
change, of knowing your genres, about knowing
your ups-and-downs of the rhythm of the story,
and it would just become part of you and you
wouldn’t even have to think about it.
So that’s my goal for writers, to really
learn this as a dance (like you would learn
the tango) and learn to dance this story without
even thinking.